all right jimmy yes sir jimmy uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally i grew up in birmingham
alabama
i was born there in 1980
uh
coming from
originally very poor my father's side of
the family my granddad
literally had a hunt for squirrels for
breakfast before school in the morning
and on my mom's side there are
immigrants from italy
but they
on both sides of the family they were
able to pull themselves up so i
i grew up
having everything i want it was a very
still magnolias
kind of childhood
in the south
and
everything was
really nice until everything kind of
started breaking apart
one of the first things
i remember really grabbing my attention
was my uncle buddy he was a pharmacist
he had sold the pharmacy and he was just
there to
show the people that bought it how he
did things
and as he was doing that somebody came
in to rob the pharmacy for drugs
and beat him to death
right there in the pharmacy and he was
all over the news
for weeks so every time it would come on
it would just cause more crying
and it was very frightening for a child
to know that this
man that was so nice and loving that
somebody had hurt him
um not very
not very much long after that
my sister had a friend cricket and i had
a friend brandon
one day they didn't show it for school
when my mom picked us up she was bawling
and what happened was their parents got
a divorce
and that night their mom had given him a
bath given them sleeping pills
shot both of them and then shot herself
so i knew from a very young age
that violence and death can happen you
know a lot of
people retain this immortality nothing
can happen and be well into their early
20s but not me
i knew what could happen
we moved from the little town we lived
in to
inside of birmingham and the first year
i was at this middle school it was like
uh
lean on me
these guys have been held back huge huge
kid like 16 gang fights i was not used
to that scared me terribly
and being as short as i was and being
the new kid i was picked on
relentlessly i remember going to school
was a horror show
i would hold
having to go to the bathroom because i
was too scared to go into the bathrooms
because i would get beat up
at the last year of middle school you're
about to move to another town and i
already seen how the cool kids acted and
i was like i'm not going to let what
happened this time happen at this new
school i grew it was the mid 90s early
90s so i grew my hair long
had my pants baggy
you know got the skateboard and it was
like night and day all of a sudden i was
ferris bueller who could
get away with murder
pretty girls left and right
it was
it was amazing it was a wonderful
carefree time
where i could
do anything i wanted
but i think being picked on made me want
to be the coolest so i wanted to push
the envelope so then it was drugs
you know to try to look cool
and started going to raves it's the
mid-90s
and the first one i went to
i got some lsd and i went there and
these all these beautiful girls the
music was loud and everybody wanted to
get in and it was just it really clicked
inside me that i won't be a part of this
so
me being the manipulative little rat
that i am
weasel my way into this rave company and
when you work for them you would get um
you know your little your little
necklace with all the
parties that you vip to they have little
placards you know vip and you would
collect them if you work for them so not
only in birmingham i could go to big
cities like new orleans and atlanta to
where these rays had tens of millions of
people and even though i wasn't working
it i could get in free go past these
lines with all these
beautiful girls and their ugly
boyfriends and walk right past them and
go in and that
you know did a lot for my self-esteem
but
drugs were becoming to take a real hold
on my
on my mind my psyche the way i thought
it became everything to me my girlfriend
at the time told my parents i was doing
drugs
it caused a lot of contention in the
household because my mother was a drug
addict too but she was a
pill addict we didn't understand our
family when we go to family functions
they would pull me and my sister aside
what's wrong with your mom we didn't
know that's how she always acted my
friends would make fun of her the way
she talked she would get my friends to
get pills for
that we didn't understand the
seriousness of it
but
during my senior year some of my friends
had dropped out and to me it felt like
they were being adults now they didn't
have to go to school they were working
so i wanted to drop out two too being
the fool i was and my dad
was just so overwhelmed
with
my mother
having to move to all these different
houses working at the post office
that he just kind of broke apart and let
it happen
uh one this girl i knew when i first met
her she was
real chubby had short black hair was not
interested
she calls me up one day the day after my
one of my cousins got in a car wreck
and died
his name was smack we call him smack the
last name is moralia he was real popular
at school too it
it really made everybody sad but she
called me she's like pick me up i got a
bunch of ecstasy cocaine
and so i went and picked her up but when
i picked her up she didn't look like she
did she had long blonde hair
it was tan really beautiful
and
my world changed
uh what she gave us was not ecstasy it
was called dxm dextromethorphan
which you find in robitussin you know
kids take the robo trip this was pure
powdered
and we weren't prepared for what it did
so it sent all of us into such a bad
trip this is kin to ketamine and pcp
it's in the same family so you can
imagine what this is doing to a kid
who's only 18 years old and didn't know
what was going on
the next thing i know i'm traveling with
her to atlanta and then to florida where
she was living with her friend nova
we're selling these pills left and right
nova's boyfriend dan worked at club
lavilla in panama city beach which is
the spot of the spot of spring break so
again i'm walking past this line of all
these hot girls and their boyfriends and
walking right into the place
being cool
you know
but things were getting sour quick we
mixed lsd and dxm one night and was on
the beach
praying to god to please please bring me
down
as we were walking away
i saw what look it was krishna the hindu
god hallucination
but was i staring at him
he blinked
and when that happened i still remember
that moment crystal clear
and everything inside me broke
everything i thought i knew about
because i grew up roman catholic
very catholic i knew
everything that was what was real right
that was what was but at that moment
everything broke apart
came back home we broke up
i was literally in bed with another girl
when i got a phone call i picked it up
she told me she was pregnant
my dad kicks me out of the house
divorces my mom tried to save his own
mind
i'm floating around
we have this child her name is sierra
beautiful little girl
but through another girlfriend i met
this guy
who had methadone
this was a very scary
guy there's a documentary called
skinheads in birmingham and another one
on amazon prime but this guy i'm not
gonna say his name because i don't need
to repercussions from this but these
were some of his little minions these
guys were violent and scary and again
something i'm not used to but i'm
becoming an addict i need these
methadone pills
so i'm living with him hearing all this
hate
nowadays they're not like that they
understand that they were brainwashed
and just full of hate at the time we're
young and these people are scary mean
i am a junkie no one wants to talk to me
everything's falling apart the world is
scary
i end up in jail
as i'm in there withdrawing from the
methadone these guys are talking about
being in the army i'm like maybe that's
what i need
so i tell my dad and he's like you're
just saying that so i'll come bail you
out no i'm really going to do it
get out of jail i joined the army three
days after my 21st birthday i ship off
to fort still oklahoma
still withdrawing off the methadone
um it was horrible at first i was short
had a short last name they loved to pick
on me
and it was bad but at the end of basic
training one of my drill sergeants
introduced me to his whole family
and said this is where i lost to 200
betting that he was going to be the
first one to
to you know skip out and go home
but i stuck with it
and made it through went through ait and
was assigned to the dmz in korea
uh first we got us there they have um
these drills in the middle of the night
where you you know put on your battle
rattle and you go do these maneuvers
it's annoying
but only two it's supposed to be once
every month two weeks later the sirens
go off people are yelling it is
not like it was last time we have live
rounds now and full battle rattle
everything
and it's two a.m in korea and as we're
standing there i'll never forget our
first sergeant says men america is under
attack someone flew two planes into the
world trade tower
again my world changed everything
was different than
they told us stories of espionage from
north koreans when we first went there
we didn't believe this crap
but on guard duty constantly cars are
passing by taking pictures of our camp
um
on one of these maneuvers these two
little girls try to run in between our
tanks and we're crushed
what a
an awful
thing to see and
when we're out in the field we have our
constantino wire our perimeter razor
wire
and they would send these little kids we
call them slicky boys and they would try
to sneak into our camp and take whatever
they could and in the middle of the
night you hear screaming you have to run
out there and there'd be some you know
12 year old boy stuck in our razor wire
that we'd have to you know pull them out
and i don't know what
intelligence did with them we would just
patch them up
this was a crazy experience um stayed
there for a year went back stateside
you're not supposed to go from one hot
zone to another the dmz is considered a
hot zone but no they're gonna send us
immediately to iraq
now on our trucks i i don't know if you
know what a split ring is on the outer
of the these huge tractor tires
on the outside they have what looks like
a giant steel washer it's huge it's made
out steel it's about you know it's
really thick people are killed by them
all the time so you air them up in the
cage
my sergeant wasn't having it we had to
do it on the truck
the first one i did i stood right in
front of but i got nervous so the second
one i did and i did like that the last
thing i remember is the sound going
and that was it
i
was on the ground when i came to i had
no idea what happened
they're like whatever you do don't look
at your arm so immediately i look at my
arm
and all i see is bone
i see my muscles contracting i see blood
and my arm
is shaped well it's bent backwards
and
it was in a legal order
that was against um
it was against the code of military
justice it was against the law to do
but nothing happened he says apologies
while i'm in the hospital
and after only a week and a half the
doctor takes me off pain pills
and it is ungodly
painful and not only that i'm not
supposed to do any work
my arms are broken and they're not even
fixing it but no my company was having
they were going to make me work
no matter what so i was like you know i
just want to go back into the hospital i
put in a request to go to an outside
doctor and the head of orthopedics was
like
what's going on i'll send you but why
and i told him i was like i just had my
arm broke my humerus
and they took me off the pain pills he's
like i i don't know why i don't know who
told him to do that
but he took care of me
but then the monster reawoke after some
time it was painful
but
it still there was also the added
addiction and withdrawal
but they sent him to iraq so then i was
screwed the last year i was in the army
was them hunting me they knew i was a
drug addict i didn't even have a tv in
my room so you're dealing with
the very organized
and very much physical
life being in the military being combat
arms
with the brook because they still didn't
fix it broken arm and the screaming
opiate addiction
and it was
i almost killed myself twice i tried to
i really did not want to go through this
anymore they ended up
finally giving me a medical out they
gave me an honorable discharge because
they knew what they had done
and they sent me home my arm still broke
two years my humerus was not attached it
was just my arm swinging around
i finally get fixed at the va in
birmingham
five months later
i'm
getting ready to go pawn some stuff and
my parents call
they're screaming crying
and i don't want to deal with it you
know i don't want to know what's going
on so
i hang up and then one of my other
friends calls
and i'm really sick and i'm just like
who died you know
and i start naming people and they're
like and then it finally clicks
i drive to my friend paul's i hadn't
spoken to in about a year
and i was like sierra's dead my
daughter's dead
i don't know what happened
and paul's like no no no no it's got to
be some mistake
so i go and sit down
and he calls my parents
and he turns me goes
sierra did die
and i was thinking how am i going to see
her mother how am i going to talk to
nicole
about this because we weren't
we weren't on horrible terms we always
just you know thought we would end up
marrying each other
after we both got our [ __ ] together
but he said nicole died too
they got into a six par
six car pileup
on the way to school in the morning in
the rain they weren't the only ones that
died
i buried them both the same day
my daughter and her little casket
nicole looking like she was that day
when i came and picked her up
and i turned in on myself
there is no one i could talk to
to understand this kind
of trauma
i hated i hated
i told god if he was real
as soon as i had a chance i would kill
him and everything he'd ever made
and i said the same thing to the devil
too i just want to destroy everything
that was ever made and i was very lonely
i didn't understand
what was
going on
and you know
that huge trauma years later that's why
i i started the nashville master class
it was going to be a a thing about music
and music theory and a
one of my therapists goes why don't you
talk about
trauma and drug addiction and
homelessness and hopelessness
help those people that are in this
situation you're in that
don't know
and also to help me
you know know those other people
but during this time
i was in and out of jail
i did not care homelessness
constantly going to jail being locked up
in a little cell
withdrawing
only the bible to read and i was full of
hate
i didn't want to hear it i just wanted
to turn my mind off
i
had decided the world was a horrible
place
that i had been tricked
and this was just my living hell forever
i
found out that here in los angeles for
veterans they give free methadone at the
va in birmingham and anywhere in the
south you don't get that you got to pay
so i came out here
they said they would give me a place to
stay
but it turned out to be a place to stay
for a month and a half
so i'm on the streets going to the
clinic
i
meet this girl jamie
and she was kind of cute
she was insane but i didn't know how
schizophrenic she was and at the time i
didn't think i could do any better you
know i'm a homeless drug addict
i call home one day and find out that
nicole's mother had sued the people who
had just made the highway
that nicole and sierra died on they
didn't put a median no yellow lines and
they'd sued them and i got a million and
a half dollars it didn't really register
at first
nothing like this happens to me
it took about three months
and the money finally came i had to go
to alabama to pick it up
my insane girlfriend didn't want me to
go because that's how crazy she was and
it took a
a week or two to get out of her claws i
went home got this check
took it to the bank
took it to the bank that it was written
on so they couldn't make me wait they
tried to i was like no it's your bank
you have to honor it immediately
and i live like people can only dream
i went from homeless
to being a millionaire here in
california i got a place on martell in
west hollywood right off sunset
and i
i got i had um
a rolls royce
i bought all this vintage
furniture uh
victorian love seats and
just buying drugs whatever i want people
knew i had but that's the thing people
knew i had money
and being homeless i wanted to help my
friends of course my good old buddies
so they would come by all the time
needing help needing help
needing help giving money left and right
i decided i wanted to buy a house bought
one in mexico
those people weren't the rightful owners
and they ran off my money
i was surprised that mexican government
got about eight thousand eighty thousand
dollars back and sent it to me but money
was going down you gotta realize i
didn't know how to handle
money of this caliber i didn't have
anything when i had everything was my
parents i didn't know how to handle this
money so i meet this guy that lived or
had a shop right down the street it was
a pet grooming place he's like we can
build this huge place over the mountain
over there in north hollywood
and we'll make a bunch of money you know
we'll make it huge
and
he knew good and well as a junkie he
knew good and well i didn't know what i
was doing
but i'm thinking yeah this is a good
investment i'll get money back so i give
them a quarter million dollars
and surprise even when it's being built
you're not getting who knows how long
it's going to be to turn a profit i know
that now
he knew that then but i didn't
so we have nothing and i have to sell
off the rolls i sell out the furniture i
saw the jewelry the guitars and little
by little by little by little we're
becoming more and more poor until
finally we're out
we end up here in the art district at
the american hotel living in somebody
else's nasty squalid
apartment filled with bed bugs and when
my girlfriend's pregnant
oh my god so when her water breaks
i call an ambulance
she goes the communal bathroom that's
for everybody and sitting on this toilet
going into labor trying to shoot dope
telling i've been i was on the methadone
clinic at this time i knew but i knew
what was coming
but she's telling me hold the paramedics
off
i'm trying to get i was i i ripped it
out of her hand picked her up pants down
around her ankles her screaming hitting
me carried her downstairs to the
ambulance
even in the hospital after birth he's
telling me to go you got to understand
the level of insanity
with this woman i don't mind saying that
because it is it just is what it is
she wanted me to bring her cigarettes
she wanted me to bring her dope
and i wouldn't because this was all i
stayed with a child the whole time he
was born addicted now i had people
around here get mad at me when she was
pregnant you better stop her from doing
this dope and stop her from smoking i'm
like i've been begging her what do you
want me to do tie her to a chair
but the courts
when he went to court the courts gave me
full custody and said she had no right
to see the child because this was not
the first time
something like this happened lo and
behold she had another child
by her father
this weird hard guy that been
around all the time he takes my money i
sent him money
and this guy is insane they're religious
saying they're the he holds his fan by
manipulation and sexual abuse
right so they're huge christians they're
going to marry jesus
god's coming for them he manipulates his
daughter by writing her letters saying
he's nicholas cage and this poor
schizophrenic girl believes it to this
day
that nicholas cage is writing her those
letters and he would get her to send him
watches and money i knew it was him
and when i found out about the child
that was more than likely by him it
that was finally when i was like i
don't come near me again
but this child was adopted by a family
and they would let jamie come her name
was jamie too they would let her come
and see the child
so
i was like
she wanted me to keep our child
so she could come see whenever she
wanted i was like absolutely not
you're not a good person and second of
all
i'm on the methadone clinic and i'm
homeless we are in no position why would
you want to do that
to this child
so
i made the decision
to give him up for adoption to this
family it was one of the best
sound decisions i've ever made it was in
the midst of the worst decisions
so here i am in the arts district
move out to skid row once that guy comes
from his apartment back
now we're talking fighting for my life
because jamie still being a heroin
addict is
scanning these guys
i go to the va they'd be selling dope
out there i'll give you my
food stamp card for this amount there
wouldn't be anything on a food stamp car
she'd get fronts she would never pay
them back but would they go after her
they would go after me
so i'm homeless have to figure out how
to eat
walking everywhere nasty
clothes i'm only weighing 100 pounds and
to get my methadone i've got to go
through a gauntlet of guys that are
looking to kill me and they caught me a
few times i was stabbed in front of the
va i had my head smashed into a pylon
out there over this
and they would find me out here in skid
row i was waiting on a bus and one
jumped out of their car and just beat me
viciously in front of god and everybody
the bus driver and everything he just
took off everybody just watched and he
took off
it was insane we went back to birmingham
i tossed her into doing that and i
thought finally we're safe
until one day she gets on a bus and
comes back out here so back out i come
because i'm a fool
i'm on drugs i really don't understand
what it's like
to be separated i'm in that mindset now
we're living in south central she has
this little place
i would walk to the green line every day
to come downtown to get my methadone i
was able to get enough money in
birmingham to pay those guys off so it's
a little
safer now but in south central me being
a hundred pound white guy every time i
go home i would get stopped because they
thought i was a crystal meth addict and
around that time the occupy wall street
stuff started happening and then i
started seeing it right down there at
city hall the dragnet building i walked
past it on temple every day walked past
the michael jackson conrad murray trial
that was the first one and then i walked
past the
occupy la
and so it was something different so i
wanted to be a part of that this does
have something important to my story i
promise
i had met a croaker a doctor that would
prescribe anything if you pay them and i
was getting extra methadone xanax
tablets and adderall i've been taking
adderall for days i've been up
for days
now
at night during these rallies
helicopters would start flying overhead
the lapd and one night i lost it i ran
away from the helicopters tripped over
this one poor guy he's like hey man
and i just ran off but in my mind in my
hallucination this guy was part of the
cartel and now he was chasing me
i was hiding everywhere running
i made it somehow to west west west
hollywood was hiding in buildings like
running in the cvs these people are
trying to kill me it wasn't just the
regular psychosis shadow people i was
seeing
full 3d figures
hearing audible hallucinations they were
going to kill me and they were just
following me everywhere i go
for three days
from downtown west hollywood to
to east l.a
and back three days i ran three days
without food three days without my
methadone and three days without water i
went to three different police stations
and begged them for help begged them for
water begged them for food not one of
them
not one time did any of them do anything
they didn't arrest me even though i was
begging them to because i thought i'd be
safer in jail they just laughed
finally on the third night this poor
girl saw what was going on and realized
i was in amphetamine psychosis
she calls an ambulance they take me to
um
la county hospital
and of all the hallucinations one of the
nurses was my roommate in the army but
it wasn't it was really it was really
him of all things to run into this guy
it took me a couple of days to realize
even they gave me a shot of value and i
finally slept
it still took me a few days to realize
that none of that
had ever really happened i just run
around l.a scaring the crap out of
people screaming about people following
me that was never there
i go back to the
occupy la thing and that night they
actually did raid uh fires were going
people were screaming rubber bullets
batons it was total anarchy and the next
day the mayor was
villa
county members named
it was yeah he was like and i like to
say nobody got hurt which was a total
lie
the story goes on my mom
who i hadn't seen in years my biological
mother wants me to come home she misses
me
i get on a bus finally to leave la and
go home
when i get to the bus station
there's there's nobody there to pick me
up so i called my aunt and she said
she'd been trying to get a hold of my
mom all day that she's probably out with
my sister
but my sister didn't come to see my mom
and if for some reason the sliding glass
door apartment was open so i go in
and look around call her name don't hear
it i see a her bottle of clomp and as a
junkie i am i slip some into my hand i
keep calling her name
and i finally find her dead on the floor
with all of my favorite foods
that she used to make for me as a child
all across the counter
waiting for me in little presents
i remember bending down and just
stroking her hair and saying mom i'm
home
and then i went and told my aunt she
made a huge mockery by shaking her
she was very obviously dead but she just
made it worse
they said i missed her by about two
hours
it was an aneurysm
[Music]
and then my dad's stepmom picked me up
i went to her
funeral sick and i was i was 100 pounds
i looked gross i looked like i was in my
50s it was
really bad to see and i remember asking
them so when you guys are going to take
me to the methadone clinic and like oh
no
no no that's the end this is the end of
all this
and they lived out in the country so
they locked me in their house
and
i came off methadone cold turkey
and it takes months months not like
heroin the methadone gets in your bones
and it takes months months of
just
basketball diaries
train spotting
esque withdrawals
but i finally started to see that this
terrible horrible evil world
was the drugs interacting with my mind i
was finally able to see clear
and i was happy
i had to go to jail a couple of times
get my license back because i had
warrants but i did it
and i was doing good but as soon as i
left their house and got my own
apartment it started again
they finally the va finally gave me
my disability and let me tell you about
how the va
they
hurt me for i'm scarred for the rest of
my life ptsd and physical ailments nerve
damage they did not give me
um
they did not give me my disability when
i left like they should have i had a
fight for eight years you know what they
gave me 10
100 dollars a month
i was like no no no no no because my
doctors all approved my hundred
well eventually they approved my 60 and
i got about 32 000 in back pay
met another girl who was more than happy
to you know spend my money again and
then
ended up screwing my roommate and
leaving with my car
um
a couple months after that
my brother my stepbrother who was really
close to me
we would do drugs together we'd been
doing he was an opiate addict just like
i was so he was the only one i could
really
you know
click with communicate with we had a
report and we vibed with each other
um
and you know drug addicts
are ubiquitous all over
but it's hard to try to find one that
really vibes with you but he did
he went up to nashville and got clean we
got a call
that summer he had died unexpectedly in
his sleep as my parents were going to
see him
it's been
almost a decade and it just doesn't feel
like
he's ever left but he's gone
so they asked me if i wanted to go to
nashville and do the same thing i'm like
yeah i'll try and
there
instead of being in a rehab where
everybody wants to get high and get out
of there these people wanted to be clean
they were happy they didn't look like
death they had money and new things
phones technology computer they were in
the world and they were doing it and
it's the first time
that i was like
i could do this there's another world
and i did i got clean
i stayed clean for two years
but one thing i didn't realize
is that just because you get off drugs
does not solve your problems i didn't
know at them i still had the trauma the
hate the anger
the um
the
nasty idiosyncratic behavior
that comes with having to adapt to the
streets and drugs
and
girl after girl
would go out with me and they would
you know eventually get mad and push me
out and it was always there crazy why do
i keep going out with the crazy ones i
relapsed
of course
and then started a journey
of manipulating and womanizing but i
didn't
realize that at the time i was moving in
with a girl
living at their house eating their food
living with them and i told myself my
mind you're just you're just dating them
you're just going out what's wrong but i
go from one to the other there's no time
by myself to
work on me
to work on my skills it was always latch
on to somebody else
there were some good adventures i
ended up with a girl who went to
the fairly well last grateful dead show
in chicago everybody in the world wanted
to go these tickets worth thousands and
thousands of dollars
and she
gave me a whole three day pass
took me to chicago
nice hotel
first day first set third song i'm like
i need to go i got stomach ache
proceeded to
indulge and everything i could find
cocaine
psilocybin smoking nitrous
i went into psychosis again wandering
around chicago wandering back and forth
from the concert and
all over the place i literally forgot
who i was
this is a lot of damage from the
psychedelics the psychedelic trauma i
don't know if you know much about
psychedelics and ego loss if you've ever
heard of it
you completely your ego dissolves you
can't remember who you are
being human you're just a consciousness
well this will happen to me in my sleep
and when i take a lot of drugs it
happens again
i don't understand i'm in a world i
don't i was never me i was never born
humans don't exist the universe doesn't
exist i'm just a consciousness
seeing
and experiencing these things
very scary
but i came to the very last night to
hear the their last song touch of gray
and on the ride back to birmingham
she promptly broke up with me as as she
should
and this would continue to cycle
i got clean again
lived with this young 23 year old girl
but still i would get on every single
dating site and new girl all the time
just so codependent girl after girl now
it became i think it's also something to
do with being picked on
so much and made fun of well look how
many girls i can get
ended up
back homeless
was on the methadone clinic couldn't pay
for it back to heroin
back to crystal meth
and then one day
in a state of psychosis this guy beats
me
beats me
hard
now i'm walking around
nashville bloody blood dripping off of
me i go buy some dope it wasn't real but
i don't notice because i'm so tweaked
been up for days
and i'm laying
on this hill behind the store i've never
been to all night just holding on
thinking i'm going to die any minute
vomiting everywhere
i start walking i see some guy cutting
the grass with scissors at 3am at a
waffle house
this was real this guy was on crystal
matthew
well pass this door and walk up a hill
to a hospital the whole time young
please help me
please help me and i was
just
at one of my worst points the pain was
unbearable i got to the hospital
and of all things they thought i was
psychotic they thought i had
schizophrenia
and they gave me haldol
which is like thorazine which can also
cause your muscle muscles to stiffen and
make your neck turn or your muscles pull
in to me it pulls my ankles in
where i'm walking on my ankles for three
days and makes all my muscles contract
so i'm dope sick
i've been up for three days i'm tweaking
and now i've got this to contend with
i'm screaming for the doctors this all
leads to something
i finally leave there
walking on my ankles get a bus downtown
to downtown nashville my buddy
eddie was down there i'd known eddie
forever he knew my mom he would stay
with us
and he used to be a junkie but now he's
an alcoholic very bad killing himself
his face was bloated but he was my
friend
the first night again i stayed up
hallucinating
the next day i stopped hallucinating and
hollowed my way closer downtown
and there's this guy in a car that's
russian he says okay come here do you
know where to find any dope aha
away out of this mess out of this misery
so i get in the car with him go to the
same guy that screwed me over the night
before bought more fake stuff so now
this russian guy thinks i did it i've
got the real dope and i screwed him over
so he's holding me hostage
in his car he's delivering race cars he
has this huge trailer behind his car and
he's driving around nashville screaming
at me hitting me i'm like i don't have
it that sky screwed us over
we ended up in the worst part of
nashville that's very hard to find
because nashville is really nice all
over
but we're in a horrible place he picks
up these guys
buys crap so now everybody's in the car
people i don't know guy holding me
hostage everybody's smoking crack
one of the guys back there gives me a
hit i don't really want it but i'm so
sick i'm down for anything
about
five minutes
or less
oh it's not gonna go crazy this is where
i'm winding down
so
i he finally lets me out
and
i'm walking away and
everything in my life is
culminated
to this point this is what i mean i was
winding down to this
i am sick i've been up for days
and i go to the walking bridge in
nashville
over the um cumberland river
i'm looking over
and i'm like why do i keep becoming
homeless there's so many people that
never have to do why do i keep going
back to drugs why does everybody i try
to have a relationship with
push me away why are you so and i was
like why don't you just jump just do it
just just why do you want to keep living
like this is always going to happen it
keeps happening
and i had an epiphany
it's because you're a manipulative
selfish
jerk
that never learned to live on his own
you live on hatred from the trauma
that's happened to you
and you're trying to pass that hatred
and negativity onto everybody else
because you feel you deserve it
and you're always waiting for external
forces to bring you happiness
but why don't you just try being happy
inside i think people like that feel
that's their role
in life in the universe is to be mad to
have this negativity
but i realize you didn't have to be like
that
and then i realized all those girls that
pushed me away all my friends they
weren't crazy
it was me it was always
me
and i walked off that bridge
and i never went back to methadone
i got on suboxone for a while it didn't
cause me to get high like methadone
and i started volunteering
working with animals
talking to vets
and just learning
to care about others empathy that was
what's going to save me
from this trauma from these nightmares
from this constant hatred of things that
have happened the only way to deal with
it is to negate that
to be positive to show love that's the
only thing that could save me
so that day on that bridge
when all that happened
it
caused a spark in me
to change and to learn that i'm never
there i've never got to a point where
now i know i'm good
every day i grow every day i'm going to
do something to make my life tomorrow
better and to make life for others i
love to donate to the beagle freedom
project the aspca the humane society
saint jude wounded warrior to give to
others not do it so you can say hey look
what i did dude because these people
need it don't you know how it felt to be
like that
and that
that is what let me survive that's why
i'm still alive
now i teach music theory
and guitar online
taught myself i spent years learning
music theory i learned how to weld
how to work with metal metal metal
production it
there's so many things i've learned and
excelled at
and
now this crappy tiny little channel that
i could care less about
fame or monetizing it i just want
to help those people that felt
that way and so they know there's other
people like that
and i like to know other people like
that it's good i need
to have that kind of communion with
other people who have gone through that
trauma
and that
that's what saves me that's what makes
me wake up every morning
and
yeah there's so much more i could tell
what stories like that
all day and never end but this is a good
place
to end for today i think yes
well thank you mark thank you jamie
thanks hell of the story thank you very
much thank you for the opportunity thank
you very much
you